oh hello there I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
a very special edition of Abby's kitchen
called toilet talk we dive into anything
poopy and come out the other end with a
better understanding of your gut now
today's letter comes from my friend Mary
Dear Abby I'm expecting in a few months
and based on some of the research out
there I'm starting to learn how
important gut health is and that as a
mom I can influence the gut health of my
baby so my question for you is how can I
ensure that my baby has the healthiest
gut ever signed mama to be Mary thanks
Mary
absolutely as mamas to be we have a huge
influence on our baby's health
specifically our baby's gut health
we are the first help colonize our
baby's microbiome and our microbiome is
basically a collection of microorganisms
that live on or within the body now
research suggests of having great
diversity in the bacteria in our gut
within that first year of life can help
to reduce the risk of irritable bowel
disease type 2 diabetes obesity and
allergies and the good news is there are
lots of things we can do to help let's
talk about them number one moms diet so
what you eat can actually have a huge
impact on the gut microbiome research
suggests of the diet high in sugar and
fat can actually cause microbiome
imbalance and a reduction in the good
bacteria while a diet rich in fiber
veggies and probiotic foods like kimchi
and yogurt can actually help increase
the good bacteria so always make sure
you're getting your fix number 2 vaginal
delivery now this might come as a bit of
a surprise to you but pooping during
labor might actually be kind of a good
thing stay with me honestly so recent
suggests that delivering vaginally is
the ideal scenario when it comes to
promoting a healthy microbiome because
the baby gets exposed to the vaginal and
yes even a little bit of the fecal
bacteria basically the more bacteria the
better while cesarean deliveries can be
life-saving research suggests that
babies born by c-section tend to miss
out on that bacterial exposure they tend
to have higher rates of allergies asthma
and other
sensitivities if you need a c-section
then don't mess around protect yourself
and your baby but it's just something to
think about if you're considering an
elective surgery
number three breastfeeding so the really
cool thing about breast milk is that it
contains its own microbiome which helps
to establish healthy gut bacteria in
newborns while I'm a huge advocate of
fetes best research does suggest that
formula-fed babies tend to have higher
amounts of the not so good bacteria like
enterococci or Clostridium and lower
amounts of the really good bacteria like
bifida bacteria
having said that the good news is for
moms who can't or just not interested in
breastfeeding there are nailed lots of
formulas out there with added probiotics
that can help to colonize your baby's
gut number for solid food apparently the
type and timing of the foods that we
introduce at weaning can significantly
impact the gut microbiome of our babies
so here are some recommendations first
of all you want to introduce iron rich
foods at six months onwards after
breastfeeding then as the baby gets
older you want to think about
introducing some prebiotic and probiotic
foods so prebiotic foods are basically
the fuel for the good bacteria and they
include fiber rich foods like vegetables
whole grains and beans where probiotic
foods are actually the foods to have
good bacteria themselves so these are
foods like yogurt and kefir the good
news is all these foods are super tasty
and really good for you regardless
number five over sanitizing we as humans
have become a way to clean and I know as
a mom our instinct is to keep our kids
[ __ ] and span however research suggests
that over sanitizing may actually
increase the risk of allergies and other
immune disorders so put that hand
sanitizer away mom and let your kid get
outside and get a little dirty
and finally antibiotics so in a lot of
cases antibiotics are imperative and
definitely save a lot of lives
however antibiotics are not
site-specific so the problem is when
they wipe out the bad bacteria they also
wipe out the good bacteria so this in
turn can of course impact our baby's
microbiome when taken before during or
after pregnancy so always make sure that
you're up in your own probiotics if
you're put on a course of meds well Mary
I hope this gives you a little bit of
clarity when it comes to your baby's gut
health
the bottom line is regardless of your
birth
circumstances there are a lot of little
ways that we could help to improve
babies microbiome well I hope you guys
all enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me
some comments below on your thoughts on
improving the babies microbiome
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]